[Music]
so what does a mass shooter have in
common with an Islamic terrorist well
they're able to create an impact that
reaches beyond their own marginal
insignificance even a small evil pebble
can make large ripples expanding across
the water a loser can kill his way to
fame with a bomb a truck or a gun a mass
shooter in a small town can hijack an
entire country's attention in one
afternoon it's the same mechanism
creating an impact beyond one
statistical importance morbid acts bring
attention suffering expands from the
immediate victims outward through cities
than country the media enlarges the
impact we can't help it it's our job but
it only makes it more likely to happen
again those new ripples persuade another
feed dying for infamy why do celebrities
unleash attention-grabbing tantrums
after a shooting perhaps they wish to
create an impact beyond their minor
importance to the only solution
recognize what underlies the crime a
thirst for infamy then deny it and then
laud the citizens out there willing to
risk their lives preventing further
bloodshed that's the silver lining in
this very ugly cloud the local heroes
who risked it all to stop the horror a
good guy with a gun and a good guy with
a truck two things the media hates
despite being terrified and nearby
Stephen Willeford grabbed his gun and
shot the fiend through his body armor
Jonny Langa Dorf then gave chase
accelerating the ghouls demise the
coward who killed killed himself it's
still pretty awful but at least this
pair made it slightly less so those are
pebbles that deserve the wider Ripple -
pebbles with the impact of a million
rocks
here's tape of Jonny Lang a Dorf who was
the guy who chased down the suspect and
drove him to suicide I pulled up on the
intersection and I saw the shooter
coming from the cars actually got right
outside the church that were parked is
vehicles parked door open engine running
and him and the neighbor across the
street we're both coming out about the
same time exchanging fire and as he came
up he I never got to look at him I never
really saw him
I just I saw the gunfire the shooter got
in his truck
and the gentleman and the right with the
rifle came to my truck as the shooter
took off and he briefly he briefed me
quickly on what had just happened and
said that we had to get him and so
that's what I did you know it's amazing
they the fellow the good guy with the
gun was terrified but he still did this
these deplorable 'he's you know and and
they're you know it's a fact that the
duration of attack of a gun attack
totally depends on the arrival of a
second gun and this shows that I guess
well in the the Sharpshooter is they're
calling this guy the beindorf Plummer
leg and or excuse me
no that was Johnny got the wrong person
there but basically he because he was a
trained lawful gun owner mm-hmm who was
able to act quickly was able hopefully
able to stop more carnage of course we
don't know exactly if you look at Johnny
they're able so just so calmly explained
the situation and what they did and you
do have to wonder if you were in that
situation could you have been as brave
and I think in these communities they
figure that they have no choice right
because if they if they waited for the
police officers you're in a rural area
it could take another 45 minutes to an
hour to get to him Jesse that's an
important point I just thought of that I
mean you thought of that then I'm
stealing it but the here is the fact
that these folks have to have guns
because that this is a population I
don't know four hundred eight hundred
people I'm not sure they're I don't know
if they have their own police force
maybe they have one guy I don't know Oh
Hollywood doesn't understand that
because they've never been to that part
of Texas and they don't know the
difference between a semi-auto and an
automatic weapon so enough with the
lectures there's such hypocrites when it
comes to mass shootings and terror
attacks look what happened in New York
City after that happened you had a
Muslim kill a bunch of innocent people
and the Hollywood people said you know
what let's not
back Islam but then when some crazy guy
shoots a bunch of Christians in a church
the Hollywood evil that attacked
Christians for praying and they're so
quick to politicize a mass shooting but
all of a sudden there's a terror attack
in this country no you know we can't
politicize this at all
Chelsea Handler I mean my goodness she
didn't say a word on Twitter when the
New York City terror attack happens then
she's tweeting up a storm when this
happens and you also have the fact that
she says that all Republicans are to
blame when there is a mass shooting well
when a Muslim kills a bunch of
Christians in this country she doesn't
say all Muslims are to blame and how
Hollywood makes so much money
glamourizing gun violence but they don't
want regular Americans to protect
themselves against gun violence and the
other difference is you have radical
ideology in terrorist situations that
unites these people there's usually an
immigration or a foreign element
involved as well
but when you have a mass shooter there's
almost never a foreign situation it's
always someone snaps like this so it's
very easy or easier to wage a war
against terrorism because there's trace
evidence there's a foreign situation you
know they want to kill all of us just
because we're Americans but you can't
fight a war against crazy because crazy
anybody can just flip on a dime like
that and do unspeakable things to
anybody at any time
and I think regular Americans understand
the difference Hollywood doesn't I would
say that Chelsea Handler was drunk when
she did those tweets but that's an
insult to alcohol I would never do it
Kimberly can I play this is Donald Trump
labeling this incident as a mental
health problem I think that mental
health is your problem here this was a
very based on preliminary reports very
deranged individual a lot of problems
over a long period of time we have a lot
of mental health problems in our country
as do other countries but this isn't a
guns situation I mean we could go into
it but it's a little bit soon to go into
it but fortunately somebody else had a
gun that was shooting in the
direction otherwise it would have been
as bad as it was it would have been much
worse so he's kind of like focusing I on
not the tools but the intent so you have
a person who is mentally ill with a gun
and you have a person who is a good
person with a gun
I'm not so sure though that the once you
labeled it a mental health problem what
can you do next there's a lot of people
miss like that I think half the shooters
during Obama's presidency had seen had
see psychological help and hmm nobody
caught them beforehand well that's what
makes it extremely challenging right
people struggle oh and they want to like
grasp but something say okay let me
explain this we make sense of it and yes
it fits your ideology and you're against
you know gun ownership and you want to
ride away have your kind of quick
trigger response to mass shootings is Oh
blame the weapon or the implementation a
you know of evil whether it's a vehicle
whether it's a gun etc but in this
situation I mean the laws were you know
fault he wasn't allowed to carry he was
allowed to own with them but not to
carry on his person so he was violating
the law there is clearly an individual
who has a very disturbed pass assault of
conduct domestic violence you name it
okay a lot of anger directed at his
former in-laws at Christians at the
situation was hot what happened with the
military where he blamed his ex-wife so
this is somebody who had made these kind
of threats before so yeah it's the exact
type of individual that you don't want
to be in a possession of a weapon like
this but never that nevertheless I'm
it's a tragic you know situation and he
was very angry about that church and
about Christians and an atheist and
there's a whole host of things here that
sort of came together in a perfect storm
of violence and horrific loss of life I
know I just think you've got 330 million
people there's how do you handle like
you don't know what what you how can you
predict something like that there are a
lot of people who don't like their
in-laws 99.99% wann do not go and kill a
church full of people because they don't
like their in-laws but I want to ask you
something about why this debate
afterwards never seems to go anywhere
because because immediately after
people impune other people's motives
they say you have blood on your hands
you know they say or if you're part of
an array you have blood on your hands
there's never any factual back up to
these smears and it doesn't help and
it's like if we want to talk about
something rather than predictably
choosing our sides wouldn't be better
instead of imputing our motives talking
about it right of course but this the
larger point is the one you made at the
very top which is nothing ever gets done
and I think there's a reason that
nothing ever gets done if you look at
the political structure the political
structure is such that the NRA puts a
huge amount of money into candidates and
they have made it so that true yes and
and it made it so that I think for
Republicans it's very difficult to say
I'm going to challenge the NRA I'm I'm
going to take even moderate steps
because all of you have been talking
with hang on any questions no but it's
it's fine but I don't interrupt you
right yeah we did your questions okay so
final and I love hearing your voice
thank you my brother
but I'm just saying all of you have been
talking about mental illness right okay
so if a Republican was to say let's take
some steps in terms of limiting access
especially to assault weapons from
people who have demonstrated mental
health problems guess what the NRA would
go after and they would start score
carding and say this person is not going
to be elected Donald Trump got a
tremendous amount of money from the NRA
what is he saying over there oh well it
may be cemento unless you know what
listen it's kind of early to talk about
this which is at this point so tired on
them I don't know if there's well I'm
just trying to figure out but I can't
believe though people say oh this is
about Hollywood Hollywood forget
Hollywood this is about 26 people dead
while they're in church awful it's
unbelievable and unbelievable is five
weeks after some nutcase starts firing
at people at a concert and this comes
you know I mean it just goes on and on
in America they had a shooting in
Colorado guy shoots three people dead we
had another shooting yesterday even
before this one two people that it just
goes on every day the carnage you guys
talk about Chicago and yet why does
nothing get done it in my opinion the
because of the power of the NRA and the
power of people who say you know what I
think this is now a cultural highly
politicized issue if you're a good
conservative you're all about gun rights
at any cost and that is terrible but
there's an underlying again you're at
your impugning the fact that okay an NRA
member doesn't want to get anything done
the overwhelming number of NRA people
are people that know how to use guns
they're law-abiding far their lives I'd
say that I didn't say an RA members NRA
members do want something it's the NRA
that doesn't want anything
so the NRA wants more mass killings no
but you take for example something like
a bump stock remember that conversation
after Vegas do you think anything got
done do you think Republicans ever ATF
is reviewing it now I'm saying that the
politicians can really did I get it but
I think it's an oversimplification to
say and try to pigeonhole this and say
this isn't right now the NRA members but
the NRA I mean the NRA members are
represented by the NRA and I don't think
oh because they don't like this any more
than anyone else but they don't want you
to take their gun so they can defend
their family or their loved ones and
thank God the guy of law abiding Patriot
came in and stepped up you know this is
the argument that says oh a good guy
with a gun will stop a bad guy with a
well the good guys with the guns weren't
there in time to stop 26 people from
losing their lives there was 50 in the
church at the moment he did help at the
moment what we have he was running away
at the moment what we have is a
situation where the NRA reacts to people
who are on their right who want even
less in terms of gun care so they always
are pushing and pushing and pushing
nothing absolutely nothing terms it's
just last I can't let you get away with
this wand to say that the shooter was
already running away when this heroic
guy stepped in with illegally by around
after future party furniture to
denigrate his heroism oh okay then a
great no one terrorism what I'm saying
for you as he was leaving so let's
to say oh that's usually this is where
it ends up celebrate agreement